our galaxy the Milky Way counts billions
of stars rotating around its center it
is a huge galactic merry-go-round but
it's not only the stars that are moving
around in it
there are also nebulous spots or nebulae
they are practically invisible to the
naked eye only some of these celestial
bodies the brightest ones can be seen
it's quite a different matter however if
we look at the starry sky through a
telescope what will we see there today
we're not going to talk either about
black holes or big bangs or even
galaxies in this video I am going to
tell you about the closest and largest
neighbors of the solar system let's get
to it
[Music]
things concealed by the Stars nearest to
us will attract scientists amateur
astronomers and science fiction writers
from the earth for decades if not
centuries to come ways to gauge the
magnitude of the universe differ from
each other but it is generally true to
assume that the solar system stretches
in all directions as far as one
Lightyear from the Sun beyond that
frontier just a few light years away
from the earth there are the stars
closest to us
the closest out of the 200 billion of
those in the Milky Way every star is an
exploding hydrogen ball resembling our
Sun and each of them is unique
the Sun the basis of our system is the
closest star to the earth unlike other
stars it is clearly visible in broad
daylight as for other celestial bodies
in the infinite space they can be seen
in the night time however stars differ
in terms of their real brightness
scientists have defined the closest
celestial bodies within the radius of 16
light-years 57 stellar systems have been
pinpointed but only seven of them can be
seen in the sky without any optical
assistance
these are serious Alpha Centauri Epsilon
Eridani
Procyon epsilon indi Tau Ceti and 61
Cygni some of them are not just solitary
bodies but binary or triple stars so the
overall number of these celestial bodies
reaches 64 13 brown dwarf stars are also
included in the list they are
considerably lighter than the other
bodies Proxima Centauri is our closest
neighbour of all which is 500 times less
bright than the Sun it is one of those
secretive ones that are invisible to the
naked eye that could be the reason why
this object was discovered only in 1915
it is the third and actually smallest
stellar component in the Alpha Centauri
system in contrast to the Sun which
finds its way around the galaxy on its
own Proxima Centauri is locked in its
orbit stretching for 1 million years
around the two other stars
this couple known as Alpha Centauri a
and B is perceived as one star by the
observer on the earth who isn't
employing telescopes or binoculars
besides it's the brightest stellar
system in the sky
both stars in the system resemble the
Sun much more than Proxima itself
próximas color is completely different
from that of the Sun because this star
is much colder 2700 degrees Celsius as
opposed to 5,500 degrees on the Sun
Alpha Centauri a is one and a half times
brighter than the Sun and their surface
temperature is almost identical in
contrast Alpha Centauri B is two times
weaker than the Sun and about 500
degrees colder interestingly in August
2016 scientists announced the discovery
of a planet the size of the earth going
around Proxima Centauri this new object
known as Proxima B is about 1.3 earth
masses which according to scientists may
mean that this exoplanet is a rocky
world its location in relation to the
star makes it habitable it is the
correct distance away from the star for
water to accumulate on its surface
Proxima B is 7.5 million kilometers away
from its star and it is likely that it's
blocked that is it faces this star by
one in the same side just like the moon
which shows the earth only one of its
parts by the same token it's worth
mentioning that according to scientific
estimates it would take a spaceship from
the earth about 70,000 years to reach
Proxima Centauri however with the data
received with modern telescopes it is
still not clear whether Proxima B may be
habitable speaking about the next of our
closest stars
it's another red dwarf Barnard's star
which unfortunately isn't clearly
visible either however it is the fourth
nearest star after wolf and la Erland
and is located in a completely different
direction namely in the constellation of
Ophiuchus and 1.7 light-years further
than Proxima this little star is
considerably smaller than the Sun being
only point one seven of its mass and
diameter in fact it was discovered
comparatively recently even though it's
the fastest moving star in the sky
crossing the distance equal to the
diameter of the full moon in 180 years
the flying bar Ned is notable for its
rapidity of movement it moves towards
the Sun and eventually it is going to be
closer to us than Proxima Centauri the
color of the star is the direct
indicator of the temperature on its
surface just like a metal rod which when
heated first turns red then orange after
that yellow then white and finally blue
for decades Californian scientists have
been making great efforts to discover
planets in the vicinity of barn and star
but so far there are no data as to their
existence here is another cluster of
brown dwarves the constellation of Vela
or sails located in the southern
hemisphere this constellation is our
second closest star after the Sun
interestingly it is difficult to observe
from the territory of Eurasia you can
see only part of it in the southern
regions of Russia and the more to the
South you are the higher the chances to
observe the constellation by the way the
best conditions for observing at least
some parts of it are in February
speaking about the stars of this
constellation the brightest one should
be mentioned first gamma velorum it has
also nicknamed the spectral gem of
southern skies for its rays which boast
incredibly bright emission lines
opposed to dark absorption lines which
are generally more common that is the
reason for the rather exotic spectrum of
the gamma star 800 light-years away from
us this star is the second largest in
the constellation and is made up of at
least six components also gamma to
valorum is also generally considered
rather bright it includes several stars
one of which belongs to the wolf rayet
set of stars but these aren't all the
massive bodies in the Vela constellation
for example the mass of the lumen 16
system is 30 Jupiter masses with its
brightness flaring up and fading from
time to time it is almost 7 light-years
away from us at the same time the mass
of another component of lumen 16 equals
50 Jupiter masses this binary stellar
system was discovered comparatively
recently in 2013 while no celestial
bodies or exoplanets have been
discovered in its vicinity
we really love and appreciate our
audience that is you dear viewers that's
why we try to provide exciting content
worthy of your attention it is thanks to
you that we improve and carry on in our
spaceship
your views are the best motivation for
us to create more videos about stunning
facts about the infinite universe so
we'll be on cloud nine when we see
you're like under this video and a
comment with some fascinating and
unconventional ideas you'd like to check
out in our next video see you later dear
friends
[Music]